I think there's a general impression  that the best science fiction writers  are American and British is that your  opinion well it's hard for me to say I  read science fiction only in English and  I my own surroundings my own circle of  friends of all the english-speaking  science fiction writers but I know for  instance that right now Stanislaw LEM  a polish science fiction writer is  considered one of the best in the world  and there are there are science fiction  writers in the Soviet Union that are  highly thought of and I suspect that in  time to come more and more there'll be a  diminution of the rank of the of the of  the English speaking domination of the  field more and more we will be aware of  non English science fiction  you